[موسيقى]
اغواء وخطيئه زنا ودنس حرام وفساد هكذا
اختصرت الاديان السماويه اي جماع بين
امراه ورجل خارج اطار الزواج وهكذا منعوا
النقاش في العلاقات الرضائيه حسب الجدل
فقالوا الجسد ملك للخالق فقط وممارسه
الجنس لا تجوس الا بشروط نسبت ايضا للخالق
اما من يمارس حقه بالتصرف بجسده فهو
تلقائيا ضد الدين يجلد او يحاكم او في
ابسط الحالات ينبذ ويهان لكن وفي زمن
وسائل منع الحمل وفحوص ديان اي ماذا لو
اعطي الانسان حريه في الاختيار فيمتنع عن
الجنس قبل الزواج ان يشاء او يقيموا علاقه
جنسيه دون زواج ان يشاء وماذا لو اخرج ما
يجري في غرف النوم من القوانين الجنائيه
الجنس
اطار الزواج من التجريم الى الرضائيه في
فلك الممنوع
مثل انا شخصيه مع المساكنه كانت تجربه
قاسيه نوعا ما
تعرضت له
بالوصف اجتماعي من قبل الجيران من قبل
الناس التي تعرف باننا غير متزوجين وقد
قلنا هذا للعديد من الناس يعني فكان
العقاب يعني
عقابا اجتماعيا شديد في العديد من المرات
والشعور بالوحده يعني قاسي شعور بالوحده
يصحبه شعور بالخوف كذلك
[موسيقى]
الفصل 490
العلاقات الجنسيه خارج اطار الزواج
وكذلك الفصل 491
لتجرب
الخيانه الزوجيه موضوع مبني على اساس
النفاق الاجتماعي
والمرجع الديني العائله الحي الذي نسكن
فيه ممكن
[موسيقى]
تقدم معلومات للشرطه الفنادق كذلك هناك
صعوبات لان
الفنادق تطلب عقد الزواج المهم في المغرب
الجميع يفعل على احد يقول هذا هو المشكل
[موسيقى]
ما سبب لمشاكل هذا الموضوع لانه انا ما
جهرت في علنا وما كنت عم حارب في مجرد كنت
عم اعيش حريه الشخصيه وعم اعيش مبادئ
وقناعاتي بعض المشاكل اللي واجهتني هي من
بعض الجيران اللي كانوا ينظروا بنظره
غريبه او بنظره بدهم يحاولوا يعرفوا شو عم
بصير بدهم يحاولوا يعرفوا الشخصين مجوزين
ولا مش مجوزين لانه بتعرف نحن عنا
بمجتمعتنا ما بيتركوا الانسان بحاله حتى
لو تعتبر جزء من الحريه الشخصيه ولكن
البشع بالموضوع هو كل الوقت الانسان اللي
بيكون عم بيعيش مبادئه وحاسس بالغلط وحاسس
بالذنب بعض المرات نحن نتطور والتطور لا
يمكن لاي انسان ان يقمع او يوقف هذا
التطور
[موسيقى]
العلاقات الجنسيه الرضائيه خارج اطار
الزواج هو موضوع هذه الحلقه من برنامج
فيفا لك الممنوعه وابدا مع سؤال الاساسي
وجوهري لتحديد اسس النقاش لماذا نمارس
الجنس ساطلب من كل الضيوف الاجابه بشكل
مختصر على هذا السؤال وابدا من القاهره مع
الدكتور حذيفه المسير استاذ العقيده
والفلسفه المساعد بكليه اصول الدين جامعه
الازهر اهلا بك دكتور حذيفه لماذا يمارس
انسان القرن 21 الجنس اهلا بكم وسهلا بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم يعني سؤال مرتبط
بغرائز
وضعها الله تعالى في الانسان لكي يضمن
لهذا النوع الانساني ان يستمر وان يبقى
ليحقق الخلافه الالهيه التي وضعها الله
تعالى لها شكرا لك من الرباط المحاميه
ورئيسه جمعيه كيف ماما كيف بابا غزلان
ماموني اهلا بك يا غزلان كيف تنظرين على
الممارسه الجنسيه في المجتمعات الحديثه
شكرا على الاستضافه
انا كنظن بان ممارسه الجنس هي جزء من
الحريات الفرديه
كتمارس كحريه فرديه وكل فرد عنده عنده
الاسباب ديالو اللي كايمارس بها الجنس
واللي كيتانع منها من ممارسه الجنس
اذهب بنفس السؤال الى تونس مع الدكتور في
العقيده والفلسفه الاسلاميه في جامعه
الزيتونه والامام الخطيب في الجامعه
الاحمدي بالمرسى بالقاسم القاسم اهلا بك
دكتور بلقاسم كيف تجيب على هذا السؤال
باختصار نفس السؤال شكرا لكم على هذه
الاستضافه ابتداء ولكن عندي مشغل مشكله مع
طرح الموضوع على اعتبار لابد من التفرقه
بين الخطا وبين شرعنه الخطا
ليست لنا مشكله مع الخطا وانما المشكل مع
شرعنه الخطا تحت غطاء قانوني معين باسم
الحريه فلابد من تحرير المصطلحات ابتداء
الخطا هو ان شرعنا للخطا في اطار قانون
الخطا هو امر جبلي طبيعي بشري فتر عليه
الانسان من اجل استمرار حركه الحياه اما
ان شرعنا
خارج اطار الزواج هو
نعم اما يعني هذا ربما مشكل يعالج بطريقه
اخرى اما انه شرعنا الخطا اصبح المشكل
منطلقا من اساسه واصوله ابتداء الانسان
الحديث اليوم ان كان ذكر او انثى رجل او
امراه او اي نوع اجتماعي اخر لماذا يمارس
الجنس في هذا القرن هل فقط للتناسل كما
قال الدكتور حذيفه لانه يعني امر الهي ام
هناك اسباب اخرى ام لانه حريه فرديه كما
قالت السيده غزلان اولا شفت القيم هي
معاني مجرده كيف ننزل تلك القيم لتكون
واقعا سلوكيا ما ثم حتى واقع سلوكي مجرد
على القيم ثم حتى واقع سلوكي اذا كان
الواقع السلوكي هو مبني على اراده فرديه
مستقله عن المثير الخارجي وعن المؤثرات
المحيطه بالانسان يصبح هذا السلوك سلوكا
عشوائيا حتى وان وجدت الاراده الحره لابد
ان ينضبط الانسان بصله قائمه اولها سلطه
التاريخ سلطه العرف الاجتماعي سلطه القيم
سلطه الدين هذه السلطه تثبت حركه الفعل
الانساني في الحياه
على السؤال يعني ولكن ما اشرت له مهم
وسنناقشه هذه في يعني خلال هذا النقاش
ضيفنا الاخير من ايطاليا المفكر والكاتب
اهلا بك استاذ مليم كيف يقارب الانسان في
المجتمعات الحديثه العلاقات الجنسيه
ولماذا يمارس الجنس في هذا العصر
افضل
مباشره للسؤال لماذا يمارس الانسان الجنس
وكما تفضلت اليوم لان ممارسه الجنس اليوم
ليست هي ممارسه الجنس عبر التاريخ
ممكن ان نجد هناك بعض التقاطعات بين
الممارسه في السابق واليوم ولكن اليوم
اكثر من اي وقت مضى اصبح الجنس متعه
بالاساس اي ان
فكرهنا عن الجسد فكره عن النسل فكره عن
المال والمصير بصفه عامه تغيرت بشكل جذري
وحتى علاقه الانسان بتملكه لجسده تغيرت
ولهذا اصبح الانسان يمارس الجنس
للمتعه اولا
قبل ان يمكن ان تنتج على هذه المتعه
نسل او اي شيء اخر على كل حال
امام هناك اختلاف في وجهات النظر حول
مساله يعني تعريف هذه الممارسه الجنسيه في
المجتمعات الحديثه ساسال دكتور حذيفه
دكتور حذيفه اليوم لماذا يذهب الدين بكل
يعني ما يمثله من قيام او حتى من سلطات
دينيه الى حبس الجنس في قفص الزواج اليوم
هل تعتبر انت ان الانسان الذي يعيش في
العصر الحديث غير قادر على التحكم والتصرف
بجسده خارج ما تملي عليه المؤسسه الدينيه
او الشرائع الدينيه السؤال الذي ينبغي ان
نقف عنده من الذي يعطي الحق او يمنعه يعني
ما هو المقياس الذي بناء عليه نقول ان هذا
الامر حق ان هذا الشخص او هذا الامر ممنوع
على هذا الشخص لابد من وجود مقياس نتحاكم
اليه في اثناء الخلافات في شيء يحكم بيننا
في موضوع الحقوق والواجبات هي ان نكون
نرجع مرجعيه على
العرف او القرن يعني هناك راشدان بالغه
الرضا نفسه الرضا نفسه لا يعني ان الامر
مباح في جميع الاحوال لماذا فالرضا في بعض
الاحيان غير معتبر بحدن الاحوال يعني
ساسالك سؤالا حين يعني انقل اخبارا
للمجتمعيه الى دوله اخرى مخالفه لدولتي
علاقه رضائيه بين الطرفين لماذا يمنعها
المجتمع مساله ليس كل رضا معتبرا المساله
هناك يعني حدود تحدد هذا الرضا وتعطي
للانسان حقوقه يعني لماذا اليوم الدين
يتدخل لماذا الدنيا تدخل في هذا الامر
وتتدخل الدوله ويتدخل المجتمع وهي حياه
يعني حميمه وخاصه للافراد هي تتعلق
بحميميتهم المباشره هنا السؤال هل الحياه
الخاصه للافراد ليس لاحد الحق ان يتحكم
فيها يعني ساسالك سؤالا
الخاصه انت بتجاوبني جاوبني اتفضل
بعض الاحيان السؤال للتبيين
حين املك اموالا حين املك اموالا وانفقها
كما اشاء في حالات الشخصيه في بعض الاحيان
قد ياتي القانون هنا او في غيره فيقول ان
هذا الانسان سفيهم في هذا التصرف ويحتاج
الى من يقومه او من يحجر عليه في جميع
البلدان في العالم هذا الموضوع بدرجات
مختلفه اليس هذا نوع من انواع الحجر على
الرضا الشخصي المساله سؤال واحد هل الدين
يحكم حياتنا ام لا السؤال اجابه هذا
السؤال تحسم النزاع كلها بالنسبه لي انا
فكرتي في الحياه كل انسان له عقيدته وله
فلسفته لا تجد يدين من الاديان في العصر
الذي نعيشه الان لا اليهوديه ولا المسيحيه
ومن بعدهما الاسلام لا تجديا يرى ان هذا
الامر مباحا مطلقا بحمل الاحوال هذا الشخص
المؤمن طب انا نحدد لا نحدد المرجعيه اولا
نحدد مرجعيه ثم نتفق على الحكم بعد ذلك
انا اريد ان اسال الطلاقا مما تفضلت به
دكتور بلقاسم اليوم الانسان المؤمن يمكنه
ان يقرر ان لا يقوم بعلاقه جنسيه الزواج
احتراما لما يؤمن به ولمعتقداته ولكن
لماذا اليوم ليس هناك ما يحمي اشخاص اخرين
ربما قد يكونوا مؤمنين او غير مؤمنين
مقتنعين بحريه الفرديه كونهم بالغين او
راشدين بحقهم في حريه التصرف بجسدهم لماذا
اليوم هذه الشريعه او هذا الدين يريد ان
يملي على جميع المجتمع ما يؤمن به
المؤمنون وليس ما يعني يعتقده الغالبيه
نعم اولا هناك اراده داخليه مدعه في النفس
وهناك اراده خارجيه الاراده الخارجيه هي
التي تعدل اراده الفرد الداخلي بحيث انه
يعد ارادته قبل ان تكون واقعا موضوعا في
الواقع قبل ان تكون واقعا طبيعيا لابد ان
يراعي هذه الاراده الخارجيه اولها اراده
الدين هذه الاراده الاولى ثم الحاجه
الثانيه اراده العرف الاجتماعي القائم
الحاجه الثالثه اراده التاريخ والهويه
يعني مقومات لابد ان تعدل اراده الانسان
الداخليه ثم حاجه اخرى لماذا نضع الدين في
قفص الاتهام ليكون وكان الدين جاجلات لان
الدين جاء
نحن نناقش الجنس لا سامحني الدين جاء من
نعم الدين جاء من اجل ان ينقذ الانسان من
نفسه حتى لا ينخرم الواقع المجتمعي فلو كل
ما يشتهيه الانسان يفعله ستسود فوضى في
الحياه الدين لم يمانع لم يمانع الدين من
تلبيه الرغائب ولكن نظمها قننها وفق اطر
معلومه عبر التاريخ سيروره المجتمع البشري
اللي هي في العلاقه الزوجيه من اجل
التناسل واستمرار الحياه البشريه اراه كل
فعل ليس فعلا محيزا شهوه مرتبطه بالنفس
وانما لكل فعل له اثار ممتده بعد ذلك نحن
لما نتحدث عن الجنس المنفتح اثاره في
الواقع المجتمع بعد ذلك حتى لا ينخرم
الواقع المجتمعي قال انه لهذه العلاقات
ربما اثار على المجتمع بحال لم تنظم كما
ينظمها الدين اي داخل اطار الزواج او
القفص الذهبي كيف يعني ما هو رايك فيما
تفضل به مع احترامي الكامل لما يفكرون به
وما يعتقدونه
يتحدثون وكان الدين اول من شرع لهذه لهذه
الاشياء التي نتحدث عنها اي وضع الجنس في
قفص محدد خاص بالتناسل
هذه تشريعات كانت موجوده قبل الاديان
تسريعات نابعه للحفاظ
تفضل تفضل استاذ مريم تشريعات نابعه من من
علاقه الفرد بالنسل وبالقبيله
وبتنظيم
وتدبير المني اي ان المني لابد وان لا
يخرج عن القبيله ان يبقى داخل القبيله
وهذا هو الاساس اي ان تبقى السلسله طاهره
نقيه
هذا هو هذه هي هذا هو اصل المشكل وليس ان
الدين وكان اشياء نزلت لم يكن يعرفها
الانسان
نزلت لاول مره على شكل وحي او على شكل
وعد او على شكل
تدابير تربويه لا هذه كانت موجوده من قبل
والدين حدث تاريخي محدد مع كامل احترامي
الذي تغير اليوم تحدثت عن يعني ما تفضلت
به عن مساله تنظيم القبيله اليوم تغير
لماذا نرى اليوم وطلبات في المجتمعات خاصه
العربيه اليوم هو ما تفضلت به في البدايه
وهي الحريات الفرديه اي ان حتى القبيله
تفككت الى نوايا صغيره صغيره جدا الى نواه
الكوبل للزوج الذي يعيش في شقه صغيره مع
زوجته ويتحابان ويقرران في مصيرهما ولا
يقرر في مصيرهما لا شيخ القبيله ولا امام
المسجد ولا اي احد ويطالبون بهذا اليوم
يعني برايك اليوم الدين ربما او الاديان
بشكل عام فيما يتعلق بممارسه الجنس خارج
اثاره الزواج لا تواكب هذا التطور في
المجتمعات او هذه التغييرات
تواكب هذه المؤمنين الذين يختارون هذه
الحياه صحيح يعني هذا من حقهم لان
القوانين مثلا عندما نقول اننا سوف نزيل
القانون الذي يجرم العلاقات الرضائيه مثلا
فنحن لا نفرض على الناس جميعا
يقومون بعلاقات يقيمون علاقه زوجيه خارج
الزواج من الغراده ان لا يقيم علاقه
جنسيه خارج الزواج فله ذلك ولكن ان لا
نتدخل في شؤون الاخرين الذين اختاروا وهم
ليسوا قله بل منهم علماء فضلاء لان في
المغرب حتى احكي لك بسرعه في المغرب حدث
ان ربطت الشرطه على شاطئ البحر في الساعه
في الساعه الخامسه فجرا فقيه وفقيها
يمارسون الجنس خارج الزواج ونحن ندافع
ايضا عن هذا هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين لم
يتملكوا اهل عواطفهم الجياشه تجاه بعضهم
البعض وكانما كان طيب نفرض ان تقول حريات
فرديه ويقول جزء كبير من في مجتمعات كثيره
في العالم العربي حريات فرديه ولكن وسؤالي
لسيده غزلان مامون اليوم يعني في نقد هذا
النوع من الافكار يقال لكم ايضا ولكن ان
هذه الحريات الفرديه لديها اثار سلبيه على
المجتمعات ان المجتمعات اصلا غير جاهزه
لانها مجتمعات محافظه وان النساء يدفعن
اثمانا اكبر لهذا النوع من العلاقات وان
المراه ستحمل وبالتالي قد تحمل وبالتالي
هذا سيسبب مشاكل لاحقا للاطفال الذين
يولدون من علاقات غير مؤطره قانونيا اي
خارج الزواج كيف تجيبون وتجبنا على كل هذه
الانتقادات التي يمكن ان تكون في مكان ما
منطقيه ايضا نحن كنا متافقين اكيد
العلاقاتيه خارج اطار او ما يسمى بالزينه
شي حاجه ممنوعه في الديانه الاسلاميه كما
في الديانات
الكتابيه الاخرى السؤال هو واش زعماك
الناس اللي كيقوموا بهاد العلاقه الجنسيه
خارج اطار الزواج خاصهم يتحكموا بالحبس
ولا لا
وكانلاحظو بان بعدا
في القانون الاسلامي الزينه عندها بعدا
شروط وعندها عواقب عقوبات
الشروط هما كيكونوا اربعه الشهود وخصهم
يشوفوا معينه اللي كاتمكنوا بالتاكيد بان
كانت علاقات جنسيه خارج اطار الزواج
والعقوبات راه كيما كنعرفو هو الجلد اليوم
في القانون الجنائي المغربي
الشروطش في القانون الجنائي في حيث اي
شرطي اللي كيقول لك بانه اللي كيقتنع بانه
كاينه ظروف اللي كتمكنوا بانه يقتنع بان
كانت هناك علاقه جنسيه خارج اطار الزواج
وكيكتبها يفيد محضر كافيه باش الانسان
اللي كيقوم بها يدخل الحبس الحين اللي
القانون الاسلامي واخا انا ماشي اختصاصيه
كنعرف بان
عندها شروط وبان هادوك الشروط وهذوك
العقوبات اللي في القانون هما الحبس ماشي
الجلد اذن هاد القانون راه اصلا فيه تناقض
معدين
كما قلتي الحاجه الاخرى اللي كنقولو بان
كاينين
المراه غنعطيكم واحد المثال بسيط تخيلوا
معي
امراه ورجل بجوجهم كان عندهم في واحد
المده ديال العام بجوجهم كل واحد فيهم
علاقه جنسيه خارج اطار الزواج ولا لا مع
100 شخص ياكل المراه والرجل المراه شحال
تقدر تحمل في مده عام غتقدر تحمل مره
واحده الحين اللي الراجل اللي كا يمارس
100 علاقه جنسيه في العام يقدر
ينجب 100 طفل اذن راه هذا
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للشروط وبالنسبه للعقوبات ولكن
هادشي شيء غير مفاجئ حيت حنا كنعرفوه بان
القانون الجنائي ديالنا في المغرب ما جايش
لنا من الاسلام جاء لنا من المستعمر
الفرنسي اللي ملي جاء
قام بواحد العمل اللي هو النقل الحرفي
للقانون الجنائي الفرنسي ديال 1810 اللي
كيتسمى
ونقلوا حرفيا زعما في المنظومه القانونيه
ايضا والعمل اللي قام في لبنان نعم في عده
دول عربيه تم فنفس
الدول ماشي
يا استاذ ماشي هي اسلاميه ولكن كانت
مستعمره بفرنسا ولا مش عربيه ولا ما
عندهاش ثقافه اولا سوره اسلاميه حتى هي
عندها نفس نفس الفصول اللي كتجرب كتجرب
العلاقات الجنسيه خارج اطار الزواج هذا
الشيء ما جابوش لنا
الاسلام حيث الابحاث كتوضح لنا
في المغرب من قبل ولا الاعراف ما كانتش
كتعاقب العلاقات الجنسيه
للتاريخ القادم
اللي باختصار القانون الجنائي المغربي
اللي بغيت نقول المنهج دياله ماشي اسلامي
المنهج ديالو مسيحي وكاتوليكي حين هو اللي
وضعه وهذا الشيء جاء لنا جابوا لنا
الاستعمار اللي كان باغي يعطينا الوهم
باننا نتصرفوا في الاشياء الاسلاميه
والاشياء الدينيه وهذاك الشيء ما كاينش ما
كاينش وباختصار المستمر ضحك علينا ضحك
علينا من الاخر بهاد القانون وحنا دابا
اليوم كنجي وكاين واحد حذيفه
دكتور حذيفه لديه ما يقول تفضل دكتور
حذيفه يعني وصلنا الى فكره القوانين بنكمل
باختصارات الفكره لو سمحت يلا خلصي
وزاد لنا واحد
المادتين الجنسيه خارج اطار الزواج
والافطار العالمي في رمضان باش يخلي لنا
الوهم باننا
في الشؤون الاسلاميه ديالنا وهذا الشيء
غير وهم وكما كنت كنقول لك
اربعه د الاساتذه واحد من مصر واحد من
تونس واحد من ايطاليا واحنا في المغرب
جايين على قناه فرنسيه
للحزب ديالو واحد الفشل تاريخي في
الانتخابات الاخرى كيجي كيقول لنا تا هو
الدين والدين والدين عندنا وزير العدل
اللي كان كيقول لنا انا غنجيبكم غنجيب لكم
واحد القانون الجنائي متقدم وذاك الشيء
يقول لنا لا خاصنا حكم من امارات المؤمنين
انا
بغيت نقول لكم اساتذه يا سيادي راه هاد
القانون ماشي اسلامي راه هاد القانون
مسيحي وكاتوليكي
وانا الا كنت في بلاصتي
دكتور حذيفه ما هي عقوبه اليوم هل من
عقوبه هل يعاقب الانسان المؤمن الذي يقيم
علاقه خارج اطار الزواج في المجتمعات
الحديثه يعني اليوم دينيا هل يعاقب هل
هناك عقوبه يعني تحدثت غزلان عن العقوبه
الجنائيه في قوانين كثيره في المجتمعات
العربيه تتشابه يعني حين لا يكون هناك
تجريم مباشر تستخدم قوانين اخرى مثل
الاساءه بالاخلاق الحميده او امور اخرى من
اجل
احاله هذه المساله الى الجانب الجنائي ان
صح التعبير اليوم هل من عقوبه دينيه لمن
يمارس الجنس خارج اطار الزواج وكيف تعلق
على ما تفضلت به السيده غزلان في مساله
ارسل استعمار على القوانين التي اليوم تنس
ربما الى الثقافه الاسلاميه اولا مساله
الجنس خارج اطار الزواج انا افضل
الوصف المعروف له هو يسمى زنا اما زواج يا
اما زينه ليس هناك يعني توصيل يعني تلميع
الاخطاء نعم نعم هو الزلمه هو الزنا ما هو
الا علاقه رضائيه خارج الزواج هذا هو
تعريف الزنا الزنا علاقه رضائيه
هي كلمه سلبيه في عقل الناس واذهان الناس
لكنها معبره حقيقه عن الواقع الواقع
العلاقه الجنسيه اما تكون زواجا او زنا
ليس هناك امر ثلث امر اخر مساله الحريه
الفرديه
الحريه الفرديه ما اولا ليس هناك حريه
مطلقه في اي فلسفه ولا في اي دين الامر
الثاني هل الحريه فرديه حريه الشخص في
نفسه ام حريه افراد مع بعضهم مع بعض
المجتمع ما هو الا عباره عن افرا تعارفوا
معا على مستويات محدده يعيشون بها
وبالتالي العلاقه الجنسيه تتفضل وحدر ولو
كنا سنقيس بهذا المقياس ان الانسان متحكم
في جسده وله الحق ان يفعل ما يشاء فلماذا
نمنع بيع الاعضاء ولماذا نمنع الانتحار
مصر دولتك وقعت ودول اخرى عربيه على
ميثاق الانسان ان
يتصرف بجسده له كامل الحريه في ذلك من حقه
ان يكون له له
حقا الاعضاء هذه الجريمه استاذ
لو سمحت
طيب الميثاق الميثاق العالمي لم يتحدث عن
حريه جنسيه مطلقه بهذه الطريقه هناك نقطه
اخرى
لابد يتفضل اتفضل علق باختصار لانه
الاستاذ ملين بده يحكي تفضل اولا يقول ما
قبل الاديان يعني الذي نعتقد هو ان
الاديان مع البشريه من اول من اول نقطه
ليس هناك ما قبل الاديان لكن هناك نقطه
اخرى لابد ان ننتبه الميثاق العالمي لحقوق
الانسان الصادم او المتحده لا يمكن وليس
فيهما يجبر الناس على ان يتركوا عقائدهم
ومعتقداتهم واعرافهم الاجتماعيه التي لا
تتعارض
مع هذا الميثاق لا احد يطلب اليوم المطلوب
هو
من الصعب جدا ان نطور النقاش عندما نضع
هذه القاعده هل انت مع الدين او خارج
الدين هذا صعب جدا لانه
لا اسمح لي
انا لا اعرف كيف مصر يعني فيها 10% من
الاقباض اي دين عن اي دين نتحدث نتحدث عن
الاسلام عن المسيحيه
يا اخي اسمح لي انت من قبل قليل التحدث عن
شيء اخر الان تريد ان تحصل الكل في الزنا
تحدثت عن بيع الاعضاء عن بيع كذا موضوعنا
هو الجنس خارج اطار الزواج
[موسيقى]
فتره تاريخيه معينه الدين
كان ما قبل الدين يعني مجتمعات ما قبل
الدين ويجب ان تعود الى
دراساتروبولوجيه الكثيره جدا ومنها دراسات
مصريه مهمه ايضا وما بعد الدين لما لم
يبقى الدين يسير حياه الناس ما كل الحجج
التي تدفع بها مثلا ناخذ ما يحدث الان في
الغرب هل تظن ان عندما
رفع تجريم الجنس اصبح الناس يعني يمارسون
الجنس يمينا وشمالا ويلدون
واصبح المجتمع ضائع بالعكس هناك حشمه هناك
يصل الزواج بدون شروطين معقده الان هناك
ناس يعيشون بجماليه كبيره جدا حياتهم
الجنسيه يجب الاهتمام بهذا الامر ثانيا
عندما نقول الغاء ما تفضلت به
من الرباط الغاء هذه القوانين التي وضعها
المستعمر فعلا وضعها المستعمر الدوله
العثمانيه نفسها يعني نقلت
بصيغه من السياق
الفرنسي
وفرنسا لما جاءت الجزائر هي اول من وضع ما
سمي بالقانون الاسلامي هل كان هناك قانون
مطبق في جميع البلدان الاسلاميه بنفس
الطريقه وبنفس لا لم يكن هذا موجود بتاتا
وجد مع التدخل الاستعماري ووجدت اشياء
كثيره ولهذا انا موافق ما قالته السيده
الاستاذه من الرباط السيده غزلان طيب انا
اريد ان اطرح تساؤل اخر ايضا اضافه
واساله للدكتور بلقاسم ما بعرف دكتور
بالقاسم ربما لديك تعليق ولكن هناك ايضا
نقطه اساسيه اشار لها يعني من شاركونا
بشهاداتهم وشهادتهن من تونس والمغرب
ولبنان وهي تدل على نفاق ربما التعامل مع
هذا الملف يعني اليوم هناك دراسات وتقارير
من المجتمعات ذات الغالبيه المسلمه تقول
ان هناك شرائح كبيره من المجتمع تمارس
الجنس وسط قبول ضمني خرج اطار الزواج طبعا
طالما ان هذه الممارسه سريه يعني اليوم
هذا النفاق لماذا نستمر في النفاق ولا
نقول ان الانسان له حريه الاختيار من شاء
فليفعل من لم يشا فلا بامكانه ان يعني
يبقى بتولا او لا يمارس الجنس او يتزوج
ليمارس الجنس لكل حريته كيف تجيب لماذا
نريد ان نعيد صياغه المصطلحات هو من اجل
اعاده صياغه مفاهيم وبالتالي من اجل شرعنه
فعل معين انا كنجي نغير المصطلح الزنا
علشان نغيره بالعلاقات الرضائيه تعرفش
علاش اتعرفين لماذا نغير هذا المصطلح
وغيره من المصطلحات الاعتبار وان المفهوم
مرتبط بالمصطلح فاذا قلت الزنا يعني هو
مصطلح شرعي تترتب عنه مفهوم شرعي وبالتالي
يترتب عنه صياغه قانون وفقا لهذه
المصطلحات الشرعيه فاللعب ابتداء وبداب
المصطلحات ثم حاجه ثانيه نقطه ثانيه لماذا
نحن النقطه الثانيه لماذا نحن نتوسل
بادوات منقوله ثم بعد ذلك نريد اعاده بناء
النمط المجتمع وفق هذه المناهج المنقوله
وليست المقوله من مجتمعاتنا احنا قضيه
الشرعنه القوانين او شرعنه السلوك من اين
ننطلق هل نلبس المجتمع لباسا لا يريده
لابد للقوانين ان تكون صادرا من المجتمع
وليس من غيره من المجتمع الذي اعيشه وليس
المجتمع الغربي او المجتمع الاوروبي ولكن
عند مجتمع في تونس في مصر في لبنان في
المغرب خلينا نكمل هذه هديك هي موجوده
موجوده
ومنتشر لا انكر هذا لا تحولي
طيب خلينا ندعوا للاطفال بطريقه وطريقه
علميا خلينا نتناول الموضوع بطريقه علميه
اكاديميه من اجل الارتقاء
بالوعينين
انا لا اعارضك انت ولا اعارض غيرك كل يريد
ان يتكلم كيف ما يشاء لا يهمني في من
يتكلم من اي اوديولوجيه يتكلم ولكن اريد
ان اطرح القضيه وفق منظور علمي موضوعي ولا
اتوسل بمناهج منقوله انا عندي اراده حره
مستقله فاعله وليست الاراده الخارجيه هي
التي تصنع عقلي
المنظور العلمي هو ان القوانين لابد ان
تكون نابعه بين النمط المجتمع الذي نعيشه
انا لا يهمني في المجتمع الغربي كيف يريد
ان يسوغ علاقات الاجتماعيه ما يهمني هي
المجتمعات العربيه المسلمه لان الدين هو
فاعل فيها فلابد للدين ان يكون له حضور في
اعاده بناء النمط المجتمعي احنا عنا قضايا
حارقه كثيره جدا فلماذا هذا الموضوع يمكن
ان يكون موضوعا حارقا من اجل اعاده صياغه
قوانين تفتح هذه الحريه العشوائيه التي لا
تدلل
ثم المقاربه الدينيه ربما لا تريدون صناعه
هذا
لذلك
يمثل وجهه نظر الكثير من الناس اليوم تقول
لدينا خصوصيات خصوصياتنا ويجب ان يعني
نشرع حسب خصوصيات كل مجتمع ولكن
المقاربه انا اعطيك المقاربه الدينيه طيب
هذه النقطه فقط نقطه باختصار
المقاربه الدينيه المقاربه الدينيه لا
تتدخل في الحريات الفرديه ما لم تمس
الواقعه المجتمعي بدليل وان جريمه الزنا
لا تثبت الا
بشهاده اربعه اربعه عدول من يمارس عمليه
جنسيه تحت رقابه اربعه عدول والاحاديث
الكثيره الذي جاء الى رسول الله جاءت
امراه الى رسول الله عليه الصلاه والسلام
وقال له يا رسول الله فاعرض عنها يمينا
فجاءته شمالا فاعرض عنها فجاءته من الامام
فقال لها اذهبي انا امشي اذهبي يعني هذه
علاقه بها لا تاتي الى القضاء ليطهرك
يطهري نفسك بنفسك غزلان تفضلي تريدين ان
تردي واذهب اليك دكتور حذيفه شكرا
الله يخليك شكرا انا زعما متافقه مع استاذ
حذيفه وغن
المنظومه القانونيه تستعمل المفهوم ديال
الزينه المفهوم الديني من القانون
الاسلامي ديال الزنا حينت كما قلت عنده
شروط وعندو عقوبات وانا كنظن بان هاد
القانون الاسلامي اللي
منع الزنا كيمنع العلاقات الجنسيه في
الشارع في
المواضع العموميه ماشي ماشي في بيت النوم
اذن ما كرهناش نرجعوا لهذاك المفهوم دابا
القانون الجنائي ديالنا
ولارج زعماك على الزينه ولا كيعطي اي شرطي
السلطه بانه يظن ملي كيكون عنده شك بانه
علاقه جنسيه صافي راه الناس
كيتشدوا في السجن ولكن
خصوصيات اليوم اللي بغيت نقول الاستاذ
خصوصيه اليوم انا هادشي اللي بغيت نجاوب
عليه حنا انا انا
ما كانشجعوش على العلاقات الجنسيه خارج
اطار الزواج اللي ما بغاش يديرها ما
يديرهاش ونزيد اكثر انا
ماشي ضد التربيه الجنسيه في وسط العائلات
وماشي ضد بان العائلات كل واحده تربي
وليداتها على اساس المذاهب ديالها وتقدر
تربي اولادها باش يكونوا
عزباء حتى حتى الزواج ولا شي واحد اختار
ما يمارسش علاقه جنسيه خارج اطار الزواج
احنا معاهم ما كاين حتى شي مشكل كل واحد
حر ماشي اختار هذا الشيء
كام انا عندي عندي وليدات كنحاول نربيهم
بافضل شكل
كنوجه سؤال الاساتذه اللي معنا من تونس
ومن مصر الرام اللي كتربي اولادك على حسب
المذاهب ديالك واخا تكون اللحيه ديالك
واصله للارض وغ تعلموا بانه ما يمارسش
الجنس خارج اطار الزواج الشباب ديال اليوم
راه عندهم انترنيطره كاين
كلشي يتوجه عن هذا الامر غزلان
بغيت انا غير نسول اخر سؤال عفاك غير الى
ملي نتوما عائله محافظ ملي كتكون شي عائله
محافضه
الجنس حتى للزواج وملي كيوقع شي غلط
[موسيقى]
العقوبه الاجتماعيه انا كنظن بان كلشي
متفق وانا هادشي تكلمت عليه
اولا هناك سؤال يعني اساس لابد ان ننتبه
له هل
تعارف المجتمع على الخطا يجعل من الخطا
صوابا
يعني سالتي منذ قليل دكتور القاسم او غير
ان عندكم في تونس عندكم في المغرب
يعتبرك غلط لا لا دقيقه
ليس هذا اجابه السؤال
السجن دعيني اكمل ما اقول دعيني اكمل ما
اقول اولا ثم ذكرنك تعليق تفضل تفضل
المساله كلها اذا كان هناك خطا وعرف
المقطع انه خطا ثم انتشر الخطا وبدا ينتشر
في المجتمع وتعارف المجتمع عليه كما سالت
يسمى مساله الدول التي اكثر مشاهده
للمواقع غير السويه هل معنى ذلك ان مواجهه
هذا الامر انني اسهل الخطا ام انني يعني
ابحث عن الدوافع التي تجعل الانسان يستمر
على الخطا وهو يعلم انه خطا المساله ليست
مساله العقوبه الشرعيه الدكتور بلقاسم ما
قال ان الزنا يحتاج الى اربعه شهود هو لا
يعني ان الزنا لا يثبت الا بعض شهور
حذيفه
ما اقول وبالتالي الاربعه شهود هي لاقامه
الحد في الزنا وليس لاثبات انه زنا الزنا
يعلمه الزاني حتى حين لا يراه احد
المساله تحتاج الى كما قلنا قبل ذلك الى
اعاده صياغه للفهم المجتمعي لدور الدين في
هذا المجتمع
فرنسا يعني اصدرت قانونا ضد النقاب وكان
ملزم القانون يلزم من ناحيه اخرى لبس
الكمامه وبالتالي لم يكن الامر لاجل تغطيه
الوجه كان لاجل النقاب بخصوصه باعتبار مع
انه بنفس المقياس حريه فرديه لا تعني شيء
فالمساله تحتاج الى ان كل انسان ثوابت
المجتمع تقارن
نقبل
التغطيه وجه طيب
ولكن يعني عندما تلبس النقاب لا يمكن ان
تلبس الذي اقوله الذي اقوله حين يلغن او
حين يصدر قانون ضد النقاب له كان يقصد
النقاب بخصوصه مع انه حريه فرديه انا اقول
ان المجتمعات لكل مجتمع خصائصه الثقافيه
والدينيه والمجتمعيه التي ينبغي ان تحترم
والمقياس الحضاري الموجود اذا كان ليس
مقياسه التقدم المادي فقط قد يكون ليس
الاغنياء هم احسن الناس اخلاقا وليس
اغنياء دائما هم احسن
التقى والاخلاق تتفاوت في الغنى والفقر لا
علاقه لها بالمال وغيره وبالتالي المسائل
الاخلاقيه والمسائل الاجتماعيه لابد ان
يعاد فيها الى يعني قانون او مقياس يسير
مجتمع عليه مساله
ان حدث ان احدا
لو سمحت في
اعطيني نصف دقيقه لو ان يعني احدا اخطا في
اسره هل ادخل الشرطه ام لا فرق بين معالجه
الخطا بين اننا اقيم يعني علنيه له انا
اتحدث عن خطا اريد ان اصلحه
يعني تسير غالبيه المجتمعات في العالم
تونس من تونس دكتور بالقاسم
يصبح الامر على نيه القانون في العالميه
الثالثه تطالب بالعلنيه لهذه العلاقه
الدكتور بلقاسم لو سمحت باختصار اخر كلمه
قبل
لا يصح قبول واضح واضح رايك دكتور بلقاسم
اتفضل باختصار فكره اخيره لو سمحت
نعم باختصار شديد نحن نعيش تحت اكراه
علمنه علمنه شامله انطلاقا من مفهوم
العولمه الذي يستهدف الخصوصيه الجغرافيه
والخصوصيه التاريخيه والخصوصيه الثقافيه
والدينيه والحضاره يسوغها الغالب نحن الان
نعيش في حضاره منهزمه هذا واقعنا الموجود
ونسال الله ان يكون واقعا منشود من اجل ان
نكون فاعلين واللغه العربيه تعلمنا كيف
نعيش الفاعل لا يكون الا مرفوعا طيب
غزلان عند كلمه مختصره لو سمحت لانه سيد
ملين بعد ما حكى بدي اختم معي تفضل معه
تفضلي
شكرا بغيتو ناخذ المثال ديال تونس
للعلاقات الجنسيه الرضائيه ما متجرماش فيه
ما كنظنش بان زعما تجريم العلاقات الجنسيه
كي نقص لنا من العلاقات الجنسيه اللي هي
كاينه في المجتمع
يطلع هو ارقام ديال الاغتصاب حيت هاد
المواد بحال الفصل 490 في القانون
العلاقات الجنسيه
لانهم مختصبين حيت ملي كيتمكن
لم نتمكن
سنخصص حلقه خاصه لهذا الموضوع سنخصص حلقه
خاصه لنتائج هذا النوع من القوانين على
على المجتمعات بشكل عام
وساختم معك السيد ملم لو سمحت في هذا
الموضوع اليوم كيف رايت هذا النقاش وبرايك
ما الذي يجب ان يناقش اكثر ربما من اجل
تقريب النظر او تغيير
يجب ان يناقش اكثر في نظره هو ان نعي اننا
لما طرحنا النقاش طرحناه على مستوى
الحريات الفرديه ثم عدنا للدين
وعوض ان نقول ان المساله تتعلق بالحريه
الفرديه وان ميدان الدين ميدان اخر ولا
احد يمص الدين
وفي صالحنا حتى ولو كان الاستاذ من تونس
يظن ان هذه العلمة داخله في العولمه وخلط
في هذه المفاهيم المتعدده فالامر يتعلق
فقط بحريه شخص لا يريد ان يتحكم في جسده
نظام معين سياسي بالخصوص لانه لو لاحظ
العلماء الاجلاء الذين استمعنا اليهم
والاخت غزلان سوف نرى على ان فيما يتعلق
بالحياه العامه كلها حياه ماديه علمانيه
في الاقتصاد في الاجتماع في التكنولوج
[موسيقى]